we tackle so many topics on drew's news
that's what i want to do a whole
cornucopia a mixed bag a mosaic if you
will
but i never like to get into anything
too hot
which is why instead of hot topics we're
gonna tap
tackle warm topics
[Music]
look i don't want to get near the heat i
don't want it i don't want to alienate
anyone out there who may be watching
okay but that's why judy and zaynab are
here so let's do this
ladies and gentlemen please welcome judy
gold and zaynab
johnson oh my god
judy you're an early friend of the show
thank you so much oh you are i'm so
proud of you it's such a great show
judy you're so good you're so good
you're so good oh judy i'm loving your
book it is giving me life and zainab
i have the biggest girl crush on you
ever you're you're so beautiful it hurts
my eyes
and uh yeah i'm just so thrilled to be
in this with you guys so
i'm gonna give you some stories i want
both of your takes on it the first story
women shaving their faces dermaplaning
has become a popular spa technique to
get rid of peach fuzz but some women are
taking it really far
and straight up shaving thoughts judy
oh go for it baby i know that you guys
are probably like oh no
no no no but i'm over 50. so you call me
when you're over 50 and tell me you
don't want to shave your face because
let me tell you something
i pluck for five hours a day i pluck
pluck pluck
and my eyesight is terrible now so it's
like i'm like you know i come home i
have like a five four footer people are
doing like tight rope exercises on it
and i'm like why didn't anyone tell me
about this i'm an old-school plucker
myself
zaynab yeah uh judy i am so sorry no you
have never seen a woman in a shaving
commercial
shaving her face you're not supposed to
do it
you're not supposed to do it
i am surprised i would have thought judy
would have been no but i love that she's
yes
okay here's a fun one micro cheating
now not microplaning micro cheating it's
the latest dating thing you
gotta worry about micro cheating is all
those little things like
scrolling through an x's instagram i
mean i call that cyber stalking
or dressing differently around a certain
person and like
you know just your like energy and
cadence changes
is this cheating thoughts judy um
you know a little bit i i don't know
i i was really struggling with this one
i kind of think it's cheating because
you're really not suppo
like if you're feeling like uh oh i
gotta hide this
it's kind of like a little bit of
cheating but it's not like you know
sleeping with someone
uh this might be a generational thing
but no it's not cheating if you look on
your ex's
instagram page maybe you just want to
see if he achieved his goals
what's wrong with that i mean if that's
cheating then i'm an adulterer
you know right but you're hiding it
you're hiding it
that's the key no no judy if you dress
different in front of somebody that's a
conversation when we get home but that's
not cheating
that's like therapy but it's not
cheating cheating
clothes to dress different enough
clothes to do that
cheating is a verb it's an action you
have to do something
i agree with that and words and thoughts
matter judy gold zaynab johnson thank
you so much i love you both guys